[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers in
allen einen guten Abend die schiere Zahl
von Toten die vielen zehntausenden die
immer noch ringen müssen weil sie keine
oder kaum Hilfe erreicht weil sie kein
Dach mehr über dem Kopf haben kein
Wasser keine Lebensmittel das Elend in
Libyen ist kaum fassbar es reizt sich
ein in einer Abfolge von schlimmen
Nachrichten über die Folgen schwerer
Unwetter in Libyen kommt die politische
Lage dazu das Chaos des Bürgerkriegs
Korruption und zwei miteinander
verfeindete Regierungen wie trotz allem
versucht wird Hilfe für die Menschen
dort zu organisieren und wie dringend
Sie diese brauchen zeigt Collie näher
teil
in danach hatten sie immer Angst vor dem
Meer das ausgerechnet des Flussbett das
nur im Winter etwas Wasser führt zur
Todesschneise werden würde damit hatten
die meisten der früher rund 100.000
Einwohner nicht gerechnet
doch der Sturm hat zwei Staudämme
bersten lassen er hat vier Brücken
zerstört ganze Stadtviertel existieren
nicht mehr Einwohner erzählen die
Infrastruktur sei seit Jahren marode
gewesen
wir warten die Behörden seit letzter
Woche nein seit Jahren dass der Staudamm
Risse hat dass er gewartet werden muss
wir sagten es und niemand hörte auf uns
und jetzt ist ganz da überschwemmt
gleich überall Leichen sie hängen in
Fahrzeugen in Bäumen oder in
Stromleitungen fest oder sie werden vom
Meer zurückgespült
für eine rituelle islamische
Totenwaschung bleibt keine Zeit
unzählige tote werden notdürftig in
Massengräbern verscharrt
die Lage in dana ist extrem tragisch der
liebische Rote Halbmond und der Staat
können das nicht alleine bewältigen
der gesamte Landstrich ist verwüstet in
der Nachbargemeinde albaida fast 100
Kilometer weiter westlich haben die
Einwohner die Hilfe selbst in die Hand
genommen ein pfadfinderprojekt bietet
Familien eine Unterkunft in einer Schule
an die Gemeinde organisiert Matratzen
und Medizin die
örtliche Gemeinde macht alles von sich
aus allein wir haben keine Hilfe von der
Regierung bekommen weder von der im
Osten noch von der im Westen es gibt
versprechen gesehen haben wir bislang
nichts
freiwilliger aus dem ganzen Land
engagieren sich das staatliche Hilfe
nicht funktioniert ist auch die Folge
von etlichen Jahren Krieg und Korruption
im Land
der Bürger helfen und unterstützen
einander von unserem eigenen Geld unsere
Stadt ist zerstört und in Not und wir
fragen Gott um Hilfe weil die in der
Regierung und Armee uns komplett
vergessen haben eine Region so groß wie
Sachsen-Anhalt wurde überflutet niemand
war vorgewarnt niemand wurde rechtzeitig
evakuiert erst jetzt wird das gewaltige
Ausmaß der Katastrophe deutlich
arbeitet für UNICEF in Libyen wir
erreichen Sie in Tripolis
guten Abend können Sie uns bitte mal
beschreiben wie was hier aktuell hören
aus der Katastrophenzone
Nachrichten und den sozialen Medien weiß
man ja dass der Sturm Daniel schlimm
Auswirkungen hat ihn aus Libyen
ganze Stadtviertel und Menschen sind
weggewaschen worden es gibt Tausende von
Menschen die heimatlos geworden sind
35.000 Menschen die haben jetzt kein
Obdach mehr
und mehr als 10000 sind vermisst
und es gibt auch hohe Todeszahlen die
Menschen
versuchen die unter dem schöpfergrabenen
zu bergen und es gibt wenig Zugang zur
Stadt
sie sagen die Menschen versuchen andere
zu retten das heißt die sind im Moment
noch wirklich hauptsächlich auf sich
allein gestellt und es gibt wirklich
wenig Hilfe von außen ist das aktuell
die Situation
es gibt nur wenig Unterstützung als
UNICEF sind wir ja vor Ort und auch
zusammen mit unserem Partner dem Roten
Halbmond in Libyen und jede Stunde gibt
es mehr Tote
viele Menschen sind immer noch vermisst
und es gibt einige Teile der Stadt wo
die Rettungskräfte gar nicht erst
hinkommen weil die ganzen Straßen kaputt
sind
jetzt reden wir sehr viel über die
Ersthilfe die schon enorm schwierig ist
wenn wir mal so ein bisschen weiter
bereits gucken sie sprechen von 10.000
Menschen die ihr Obdach verloren haben
wie soll es denn da überhaupt
weitergehen
die Menschen suchen jetzt natürlich nach
Obdach und als UNICEF liefen wird
zunächst mal temporärer
Unterbringungsmöglichkeiten und wir
liefern auch lebensrettende Dinge wie
zum Beispiel Winterkleidung für Kinder
dazu gehören auch Hygiene Kids und
medizinische Güter für mehr als 10.000
Menschen und wir liefern dann später
auch noch mehr Hilfsgüter
war das sie arbeitet für UNICEF in
Libyen Frau albergutti ganz herzlichen
Dank für ihre Schilderung heute Abend
vielen Dank
das Gespräch im aus technischen Gründen
vor der Sendung aufgezeichnet ein
schweres Unwetter nach dem anderen in
den letzten Tagen mit Regenmengen die
nach Experteneinschätzung so in Europa
noch nie da gewesen sind
gestern Abend und in der Nacht gab es in
Teilen von Deutschland solche Bilder
da entlädt sich etwas ganz besonders
trifft es Worms statt und Umgebung
versinken in einer Winterlandschaft viel
zu viel Hagel und Regen stürzen vom
Himmel Straßen werden überflutet Bauern
Winzer müssen um ihre erntebahnen eine
Nacht nach der die sozialen Netzwerke
voll sind mit Filmen die Menschen
vielerorts aus ihren Fenstern gemacht
haben man hört sie dabei ungläubig
fragen was ist das
Andreas Stammes bei uns aus unserer
umweltredaktion guten Abend Andreas na
Christian ja was ist das wie kann man
das erklären diese vielen diese heftigen
Unwetter dieser Starkregen diese enorme
Menge von Blitzen ja man kann das schon
verstehen wenn man da dieses mulmige
Gefühl bekommt ist das jetzt Klimawandel
ist das hautnah ist das nicht mehr
normal oder man kann auch sagen ja
geregnet hat ja früher auch und
letztlich ist das die Frage kann man
einzelne extreme Wetterereignisse dieser
Art wirklich dem Klimawandel zuordnen
das ist nicht ganz so einfach natürlich
noch mal die globale
Durchschnittstemperatur zu messen sagen
das steigt ist wesentlich einfacher als
Lokal zu sagen das Wetter das
Klimasystem hier reagiert so und so da
gibt's noch viele Fragen aber die
attributionsforschung das sind die die
beschäftigen sich mit diesem
Zusammenhang zwischen extremem Wetter
und Klimawandel die liefern brauchbare
Ergebnisse Hitzewellen z.B in China oder
in Europa wie wir sie gesehen haben mit
Temperaturen über 50 Grad das sagen die
Forscher das ist nicht erklärbar wenn
wir nicht den Klimawandel ins Zentrum
rücken und was jetzt die Unwetter angeht
da ist die Tendenz auch klar wenn man
jetzt das Mittelmeer gesehen hat in den
letzten Tagen und Wochen da sind sich
viele auch einig da spielt der
Klimawandel eine Rolle aber da ist man
noch etwas vorsichtiger aber insgesamt
kann man natürlich sagen dieser
Ereignisse und der Klimawandel das hängt
zusammen das heißt das hängt auch alles
zusammen was wir gesehen haben in den
letzten Tagen und Wochen in Griechenland
in Libyen und jetzt auch bei uns hier in
Deutschland es gibt einfach
physikalische Grundlagen die kann man
nicht weg diskutieren und da stehen auch
alle auf diesem Boden und das ist zum
einen
Starkregenereignisse werden heftiger und
häufiger das ist ganz einfach der
menschengemachte Klimawandel hat die
globale Durchschnittstemperatur schon um
ein Grad und mehr erhöht und Luft ein
Grad wärmer nimmt 7% mehr Feuchtigkeit
auf kann man jetzt sagen 7%, das ist
nicht viel aber das ist eben sagen
Forscher der Unterschied zwischen einem
heftigen Regenguss und einem der vielen
vielen Menschen das Leben kostet wie man
es jetzt in Libyen gesehen hat und
diesen Zusammenhang muss man ganz klar
sehen das ist Personal runterzubrechen
schwierig aber es ist da und es ist
nicht weg ist weg zu diskutieren man
hört ja auch viele Forscher die sagen
dass es so heftig jetzt kommt ist
durchaus überraschend und so schnell
kommt ist denn das etwas Interesse mit
dem wir dann in Zukunft wirklich
regelmäßig umgehen müssen da ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit schon sehr hoch da
sind sich alle einig denn es gibt wir
müssen uns auch an absurde oder
vielleicht erstmal sehr ja
pittoresk-szenarien gewöhnen dass diese
Regen diese flutgeschichten nicht nur
passieren sondern auch diese Luftmassen
die mehr Feuchtigkeit auf dem Dürre
produzieren denn wenn es nicht regnet
wollen diese Luftmassen immer noch mehr
Feuchtigkeit die ziehen aus dem Böden
die werden die Dornen aus und so hat man
dann den Starkregen der sich bildet ganz
woanders das ist kein Nullsummenspiel wo
dann hinterher alle glücklich sind
sondern da verlagern sich riesige
Probleme und am Ende werden wir mehr und
heftiger davon getroffen werden da sind
sich die Wissenschaftler mit hoher
Wahrscheinlichkeit einig Andreas stammen
aus unserer ZDF umweltreaktion Andreas
vielen Dank
die Welt muss sich also einstellen und
umstellen und sie muss jetzt erstmal
aktuell natürlich Nothilfe leisten Hilfe
für die Opfer ist in einem zerrütteten
Land wie Libyen wir haben es vorhin kurz
gehört äußerst schwierig doch es gibt
lokale Organisationen mit denen zum
Beispiel das Deutsche Rote Kreuz und
UNICEF zusammenarbeiten beide sind Teil
des Aktionsbündnisses Katastrophenhilfe
wenn Sie mithelfen wollen für Ihre
Spenden die IBAN lautet
de65/100 400 600-100 400 600 das
Stichwort ZDF Nothilfe Libyen Infos gibt
es auch unter ZDF und Entschuldigung
unter Spenden zdf.de im Netz und dort
finden Sie auch die Angaben wie sie für
die notleidenden Menschen in Marokko
nach dem furchtbaren Erdbeben dort
spenden können
und damit mit Marokko nämlich beginnt
auch der Nachrichtenüberblick der erste
von dir heute abend Hannah in Marokko
konzentrieren sich die Helfer 5 Tage
nach dem verheerenden Erdbeben mehr und
mehr auf die Versorgung der Überlebenden
morgen wird das Deutsche Rote Kreuz
erstmals Hilfsgüter in das Land fliegen
unter anderem Zelte und Isomatten vor
Ort würden diese von Partnerorganisation
verteilt erklärte dass DRK gebraucht
werden die Hilfsgüter auch im Gebirge wo
die Nächte besonders kalt sind einige
der schwer getroffenen Orte na das
Epizentrums sind jedoch immer noch
schwer zu erreichen
Patientinnen und Patienten sollen sich
künftig über ein staatliches
Online-Portal über die
Behandlungsqualität und die Leistungen
der Krankenhäuser in Deutschland
informieren können das hat heute das
Bundeskabinett beschlossen laut
Gesetzentwurf ist der Staat des Portals
für April 2024 geplant der
krankenhausatlas soll für mehr
transparent sorgen und unter anderem
zeigen welche Operationen eine Klinik
anbietet wie der Personalschlüssel
aussieht oder wie oft es zu
Komplikationen kommt
und weiteres Thema im Bundeskabinett war
die Erhöhung des Bürgergelds die
Ministerinnen und Minister belichten
heute eine Anhebung der Bezüge ab 2024
um durchschnittlich rund 12 Prozent
zudem brachten sie einen Gesetzentwurf
für den Einsatz von Mini Solaranlagen
auf den Weg sollen
Eigentümergemeinschaften die sogenannten
balkonkraftwerke in Zukunft nicht mehr
grundsätzlich blockieren dürfen
das Landgericht Halle hat ein
Strafverfahren gegen Thüringens afd-chef
höcke eröffnet die Staatsanwaltschaft
wirft ihm vor in einer Rede im Jahr 2021
wissentlich NS Vokabular verwendet zu
haben konkret geht es um eine verbotene
Losung der Saal also der Sturmabteilung
der NSDAP
die Ukraine hat nach Angaben moskauz die
Hafenstadt Sebastopol auf der von
Russland völkerrechtswidrig annektierten
Krim angegriffen und dabei zwei
Kriegsschiffe beschädigt 24 Menschen
seien verletzt worden ukrainische Medien
veröffentlichten Bilder einer brennenden
Werft unterdessen meldete die Ukraine
dass sie bei einem mehrstündigen
russischen Angriff auf die getreidehäfen
Ismael und Reni 32 Drohnen abgefangen
habe mindestens sechs Zivilisten sein
verletzt worden
für den früheren US-Präsidenten Donald
Trump war es irgendwie eine besondere
Beziehung er hat mir wunderschöne Briefe
geschrieben und das sind großartige
Briefe wir haben uns verliebt sagte er
über sein Verhältnis zu Nordkoreas
Diktator Kim Jong-un Trump dachte er
habe einen neuen besten Freund so
beschreibt das Trumps ehemaliger
Sicherheitsberater um im Bild zu bleiben
muss man jetzt allerdings sagen Kim geht
fremd
traditionell im Panzerzug kam er heute
zu einem Treffen in Russland fern im
Osten mit Vladimir Putin und da ging es
weniger um Gefühle als um Waffen und um
Macht garniert mit einem besonderen Menü
Sebastian
der Kreml Reporter des Staatsfernsehens
pavil sarubin ist ganz nah dran vor dem
gemeinsamen staatsdinner von Vladimir
Putin und Kim Jong-un gibt er den
Zuschauern einen Einblick in die
menüabfolge Salat mit Feigen und
Nektarine Teigtaschen mit Kamtschatka
Krabben Fischsuppe
sanddornsorbetür mit Pilzen und
Kartoffeln marmoriertes Rinder und
Rekord mit gebackenem Gemüse und Taiga
Preiselbeeren mit Pinienkernen und
gezuckerter
kondensmilchstes Essen für einen für
Putin wichtigen Gast das soll dieser
Reporter Auftritt zeigen eins wird heute
klar Vladimir Putin will den
nordkoreanischen Diktator umgarnen denn
der ist bekannt für sein für Luxus und
Technik vor dem Bankett darf Kim gab
Putins Staatskarosse inspizieren einmal
Probesitzen inklusive
in Korea gibt es ein Sprichwort Kleider
sind gut wenn sie neu sind aber bei
Freunden sind alte gut und bei uns sagt
man ein alter Freund ist besser als zwei
neue
ziemlich beste Freunde dieses Schauspiel
führen die beiden Herrscher heute auf
Kim Jong-un verspricht Putin dann auch
Russland im Kampf gegen den
Imperialismus wie er es nennt
bedingungslos zu unterstützen mit Putin
stößt er auf eine ukrainische Niederlage
an
wir sind sicher dass die russische Armee
und das russische Volk einen großen Sieg
in gerechten Kampf zur Bestrafung der
bösen Mächte erringen werden
dass das Treffen im Weltraumbahnhof was
dort nicht stattfindet kein Zufall kim
will von Russland neben Nahrungsmittel
Lieferungen vor allem Know-how im
Bereich Raumfahrt und Raketentechnik was
Putin von Kim konkret will sagt er heute
nicht doch für Experten ist klar putin
will an Kims scheinbar prall gefüllte
Waffenkammern die der nordkoreanische
Diktator erst am Samstag stolz
präsentierte
wir sprechen höchstwahrscheinlich über
Artillerie und über Munition für die
Artillerie die russische Armee hat daran
Bedarf und in der Militär Doktrin
Nordkoreas hat die Artillerie schon
immer einen sehr wichtigen Platz
eingenommen
über die Qualität und den Umfang der
nordkoreanischen Waffenarsenale ist
nicht viel bekannt das Land schottet
sich seit Jahrzehnten ab doch für Putin
zählt heute vor allem dass er der Welt
einen treuen Verbündeten präsentieren
konnte im Kampf gegen den Westen
und wir bleiben noch ein Moment im
fernen Osten und sind doch ganz direkt
bei uns hier in Europa und dann noch mal
speziell in Deutschland wo für die
deutsche Automobilindustrie enorm viel
auf dem Spiel steht und zwar egal wie
man die Sache dreht
einerseits sind Deutschlands Autobauer
unter Druck weil chinesische Hersteller
von Elektroautos aufholen und einholen
und überholen nicht zuletzt beim Preis
und dank üppiger Subventionen der
Regierung in Peking die sind der EU ein
Dorn im Auge und sie prüft jetzt
Gegenmaßnahmen
andererseits verkaufen die deutschen
einen gut Teil ihrer Autos in China und
sollte Europa Strafzölle erheben dürfte
die Retourkutsche der Chinesen nicht
lange auf sich warten lassen
was die Chefin der EU-Kommission in
ihrer Rede heute zur Lage der
Europäischen Union ankündigte hat es
also in sich auf jeden Fall Florian
erneuern
gerade hat sie 63 Minuten lang geredet
da dürfen wir Journalisten ihr noch eine
Frage stellen jeder nur eine
meine Frage wäre sie haben nicht erklärt
was sie bei der nächsten Wahl machen
werden sie wieder als
kommissionspräsidentin antreten halt
fangen wir Frauen an State of the Union
das Hochamt von Europas Demokratie nach
US-Vorbild einmal im Jahr erklärt die
Chefin der EU-Kommission die Lage des
Kontinents für Ursula von der Leyen
könnte es die letzte Rede dieser Art
sein im nächsten Jahr wird gewählt und
die Lage ist schwierig etwa für die
Industrie
auffordern bei der Umstellung auf
klimaneutrale Energien in Führung zu
gehen wir müssen nur jetzt in die
Zukunft blicken und darlegen wie wir
dabei wettbewerbsfähig bleiben
doch ausgerechnet hier kommt die
staatlich gepäppelte Konkurrenz
chinesische Elektroautos hier zuletzt
auf der IAA in München präsentiert
konkurrenzfähig bei Leistung und vor
allem beim Preis 20% günstiger als
vergleichbare europäische Modelle
glaube markets die Weltmärkte werden mit
billigen chinesischen Elektroautos
überschwemmt der Preis dieser Autos wird
durch riesige staatliche Subventionen
künstlich gedrückt das verzerrt unseren
Markt
ihre Beamten sollen das nun bis zu 13
Monate lang prüfen mit einer
anti-subvention zu Untersuchung und
deren Ende könnte vieles stehen eine
Protestnote oder Strafzölle ein
Handelskrieg mit China von der Lions
Parteifreund pvp-chef Manfred Weber will
nicht warten sondern setzt die
Kommission unter Druck
die Europäische Union darf nicht naiv
sein in der Zeit in der war uns befinden
und wer die heutigen Preise sieht der
weiß dass ich Chinesen subventionieren
deswegen das Verfahren muss recht sicher
sein schnell abgeschlossen werden aber
dann muss es auch schnell zu
Konsequenzen kommen
der Ton wird rauer auch heute in
Straßburg es ist längst vor Wahlkampf in
Europa Weber selbst wird angegriffen
weil er seit Monaten um Verbündete von
rechts außen wird für Mehrheiten im
nächsten Europaparlament
sie machen einen historischen Fehler die
Geschichte wird sich an sie erinnern sie
können nicht über eine Koalition mit uns
für von der Leyen reden und gleichzeitig
Mehrheiten mit der extremen Rechten
jagen
vielleicht sind es auch diese Fragen die
Ursula von der Leyen zögern lassen die
eine nach ihrer Kandidatur nämlich
beantwortet sie heute so
das war kein Thema heute für die State
of the Union der Wahl ist die mögliche
Aufgabe ihre erste Wahlkampfrede zu
schreiben etwas leichter geworden in
Teilen zumindest klang ihr Auftritt
heute schon genauso
wir bleiben noch bei der Wirtschaft ein
weiterer Bereich mit großen Sorgen jetzt
bei Diana der Hamburger Hafen steckt in
einer Krise und helfen soll nun
überraschend die Schweizer großrederei
MSC sie will mit 49,9% beim größten
Hafenbetreiber Haller einsteigen und hat
dazu jetzt einen Vorvertrag mit der
Hansestadt unterzeichnet Frank beetmann
was verspricht sich der Hamburger Senat
genau von diesem Schritt schau mal den
ersten Bürgermeister der Stadt Hamburg
Peter Tschentscher zu zitieren diese
strategische Partnerschaft könne unserer
gesamten Maritim Wirtschaft die
Schubkraft geben die sie in schwierigen
Zeiten braucht tatsächlich verliert der
Hamburger Hafen in den letzten Jahren
nämlich stetig Herrn Marktanteil vor
allem gegenüber der Konkurrenz in
Rotterdam und Antwerpen der
Hafenbetreiber Haller habe zu wenig
investiert in die Infrastruktur nur
eines von mehreren Problemen der Deal
mit MSC erscheint da wie ein
Rettungsanker künftig wenn man das
hafengeschäft gemeinsam führen die
Schweizer großräderei verspricht im
Gegenzug Jobs und will den wahren
Umschlag an den Hala Terminals kräftig
ausbauen
reagiert denn
jetzt ein größte deutsche Reederei die
dürfte ja eigentlich auch Interesse
haben oder oh ja und für die sind diese
Pläne ein riesen Affront man muss sich
das vorstellen Hamburg ist der
Heimathafen von Hapag Lloyd keiner macht
so viel waren Umschlag mit der Hala wie
eben hapagout käme ist so wie geplant
müsste die deutsche Reederei künftig an
MSC also an den großen Konkurrenten
Terminal Gebühren zahlen deswegen
spricht vieles dafür dass ich aber dort
vermutlich zusammen mit Großaktionär
kühne bereit macht für einen
Gegenangebot die Börse rechnet mit allen
scharfen Bieter Wettstreit ein echter
macht Kampf ist es jetzt schon vielen
Dank Frank für diese Einordnungen
mit fast 7000 Mitgliedern zählt die
jüdische Gemeinde in Frankfurt am Main
zu den größten Deutschlands heute
feierte sie das 75 Jubiläum ihrer wieder
Begründung
bundesinnenministerin ferser würdigte
die Gemeinde als einen wertvollen Teil
der Gesellschaft der Vorsitzende Korn
erinnerte an die jüdische Tradition in
der Stadt die bis ins zwölfte
Jahrhundert zurückreiche während der NS
Herrschaft war das jüdische Leben in
Frankfurt weitestgehend zerstört worden
und jetzt die Lottozahlen an diesem
Mittwoch die lauten 14 15 18 27 28 41
Superzahl 3 alle Angaben wie immer ohne
Gewähr
der Herbst kommt und mit ihm die Bilder
des norwegischen Malers Edward Munk es
ist munkherbst in Berlin und das passt
denn in Berlin hatte Munk seinen
künstlerischen Durchbruch seine
farbgewaltigen Meisterwerke schockieren
und begeistern damals wie heute
1892 wurde Monk in Berlin erst
eingeladen und dann gleich wieder
abgehängt er hat den Aufruhr damals
geschickt für sich genutzt und ist auch
jetzt in Berlin wieder und neu zu
entdecken der Zauber des Nordens Stefan
Merseburger
intensive Farben starke Kontraste rot
und weiß ein Paar das sich anschaut Auge
in Auge innige Momente die nicht von
Glück Zeugen düstere Seelenlandschaften
die Bilder des Norwegers Edward Munk
sorgen 1892 als er erstmals in Berlin
ausstellt für einen Skandal die
Ausstellung wird nach drei Tagen
geschlossen der Schock war groß so etwas
hatte man in kaiserlichen Berlin noch
nie gesehen der Kunstgeschmack damals
war sehr viel konservativer sehr viel
naturalistischer und das skizzenhafte
unfertig anmutende von Munk empfand man
als dilettantisch als schockierend
fjordinator schöne Landschaften in
Berlin herrscht damals eine romantische
Norwegen Begeisterung auch in der
Malerei mungslandschaften dagegen sind
groß radikal sie transportieren
Stimmungen die Empörung um ihn die
Affäre Munk wird zum Stadtgespräch
glaube ich wirklich ein kluger Typ auch
also der hatte sofort erkannt dass diese
dieser Skandal für ihn eigentlich eine
tolle Werbung ist und so schreibt das
auch an seine Tante dann nach Hause was
Besseres hätte mir gar nicht passieren
können ich bleibe jetzt erstmal hier in
Berlin
er bezieht ein Atelier in Schöneberg bis
1908 arbeitet und lebte immer wieder in
der Stadt er entdeckt die Druckgrafik
die er schnell meisterhaft beherrscht
Munk wird Teil der Buam dir auch
porträtiert der Schriftsteller August
ist Strindberg gehört zu seinen
Bekanntschaften und die Dichterin dann
die Jule damals als Fan verteilt verehrt
Liebe Angst Wahnsinn Eifersucht das
moderne Seelenleben interessiert Muck
fokussiert sich auf die
Geschlechterbeziehung der lautet
psychologisch aus was passiert in in der
Beziehung und das war natürlich auch zum
großen Teil bedrückend also das
Liebesglück nimmt nur ja wenig Raum ein
beimung und dann kommt die Verzweiflung
die Einsamkeit die Angst und der Tod
die Expressionisten verehrenmung in den
20er Jahren feiert seine Kunst in Berlin
Triumpfe später brandmarken die Nazis
ihn als entartet
hochkarätige haben aus Oslo schmücken
die Ausstellung in der Berlinischen
Galerie Munk Vorreiter der Moderne
wollte lebendige Menschen zeigen die
atmen und Fühlen leiden und lieben er
nimmt uns mit in ihr Innenleben
Munk war in Berlin übrigens häufig
Pleite seine Staffelei wurde gepfändet
andererseits meldete er stolz nach Hause
er hatte sich einen Wintermantel gekauft
das beeindruckendste Kleidungsstück dass
er je besessen habe Kleidung war in
Berlin viel billiger als in Norwegen
auch das hat sich nicht geändert die
Ausstellung in der Berlinischen Galerie
läuft ab Freitag und dann bis Ende
Januar
so gleich nach uns läuft das
auslandsjournal mit einer Reportage über
verschleppte ukrainische Kinder über
russische
umerziehungspropaganda und mutige
Befreiungsaktionen und gegen null Uhr 35
meldet sich dann hier Christopher
Wehrmann mit unserem heute
journal-update und vom gesamten Team
hier ein angenehmer Abend
[Musik]
guten Abend kaum sind die Gewitter
weggezogen kommt schon gleich das
nächste hoch es ist jetzt kein ganz
großes dickes hoch sondern eher ein
langes schmales hoch und bis morgen
Abend wird es sogar zwei
hochdruckzentren ausweisen es gibt
allerdings noch einige Tiefs über Europa
und jetzt ist ja immer die spannende
Frage wie viel Regen bringen die dann
mit die gute Nachricht ist nicht viel
Regen bis Freitag Abend erwarten wir
maximal hier im Baltikum so an die 50
Liter Regen pro Quadratmeter und über
den Balearen 70 literin pro Quadratmeter
heute Nacht fällt noch Regen bei uns
hier südlich der Donau sonst ist es
häufig klar und das bildet sich auch mal
Nebel wenn es klar wird dann wird es
auch kalt dann sinken die Werte in der
Lüneburger Heide bis vier Grad das
klingt schon fast nach Bodenfrost in
Süddeutschland bleibt es bei 16 bis 11
Grad milder morgen erwarten uns
höchsttemperatur zwischen 18 Grad am
alten Rand oder auch in
Schleswig-Holstein rein und 25 Grad am
Oberrhein morgen wechseln sich Sonne und
Wolken bei uns ab und einzig ganz im
Süden fällt noch etwas Regen am Freitag
kannst du noch einzelne Gewitter geben
hier am Alpenrand dann aber wird es
spätsommerlich warm mit
Höchsttemperaturen von 22 bis 30 Grad
wenn Sie jetzt vielleicht an ihre
empfindlichen Pflanzen denken ein
Gesichts der Nachttemperaturen von heute
schauen wir mal nach Gardelegen daran
erkennen sie nämlich an dem Trend dass
die Nachttemperaturen steigen tagsüber
liegen die Werte zwischen 20 und 25 Grad
die kommende Woche wird wechselhafter
guten Abend